[Música]
boa noite é obrigado pela presença de
vocês eu queria falar um pouco sobre o
futuro da experiência do cliente como
será o futuro da nossa experiência de
consumo em 2030 né 89% das 500 maiores
empresas em na década de 50 já não
existem mais
ou seja a gente vive uma série de
transformações e é claro que em 2030
tudo será diferente
a cultura do feedback do cleide ou seja
ela ajuda a direcionar o futuro das
empresas é claro os clientes falam que
eles desejam e as empresas vão ajustando
diminuindo a distância entre o que está
acontecendo que a empresa está fazendo
eo que o cliente deseja mas também
quando falamos de inovação
principalmente as discutidas
existem grandes nomes grandes e vamos
dizer é caras muito feras como o
senhorzinho está na foto chamado steve
jobs ele falava as pessoas não sabem o
que querem até mostrarmos a elas
ou seja muitas vezes o conhecimento os
novos produtos novos serviços estão à
frente do que a gente está pensando como
o consumidor está em tão grandes é caras
como esses grandes gênios ajudam a
traseira e levar isso pra frente
mas quais são os principais problemas a
serem resolvidos na sociedade atual
então vou fazer um bate bola com vocês
do qual eu vou falar um problema e vou
trazer uma solução e é claro quais
empresas quais profissionais estão
trabalhando para resolver esse problema
é isso que nós vamos fazer falar do
futuro é futurismo ou seja quais são as
novas lógicas quando a gente fala de
futurismo nós temos que quebrar todo o
paradigma atual ou seja pensar de forma
totalmente fora da caixa dizer coisas
que muito provavelmente a gente não tava
pensando antes
quais são os novos modelos de negócio e
também quais são as novas oportunidades
então vamos lá
um grande empresário empreendedor
o que nos ajudou a colocar de fato entre
outras ações né é futuro é ou seja o
futuro na frente na frente do nosso
tempo né o richard branson e aqui vai
uma dica pra quem é empreender como eu
sou empreendedor
se você tem algo no seu cotidiano no seu
dia que te frustrou o último negócio ou
seja após as dores de nós pessoas ou
profissionais são motivos para que você
cria um negócio e ele claro dos 16
negócios que ele montou aproximadamente
oito foram baseados em frustrações
pessoais
tá então vamos falar sobre os problemas
né então o problema agora é
conectividade global
quem é que é claro tem problema de
acessibilidade internet pode ser aqui
dentro pode ser lá fora pode ser no
interior em alguma cidade ou seja
internet não está disponível em todos os
momentos
é claro que a internet hoje chegou
energia elétrica né
ou seja é ultra necessário para o nosso
dia a dia do nosso cotidiano
então em virtude disso soluções para
conectividade global vão ajudar muitas
pessoas como por exemplo joão de 13 anos
que mora lá na floresta amazônica e ele
precisa é claro de internet a
conectividade acessibilidade vai ajudar
as pessoas de um modo geral a garantir
um futuro melhor
quem está fazendo ou seja quem está
disponibilizando internet acessível em
todas as regiões do mundo é claro que
num projeto de crescimento nesse sentido
de expansão
são duas empresas atualmente entre
outras mas as principais é o google eo
facebook o google lançou vários balões
satélites que disponibilizam através de
sinal via satélite é para internet para
lugares inacessíveis
então recentemente inclusive um balão um
desses caiu na floresta amazônica ou
seja existem cidade já remotas no mundo
que já são é possui internet baseados no
golo que é o nome do projeto e também o
facebook recentemente lançou uma série
de satélites para compartilhar internet
gratuita em qualquer região geográfica
dentro do lodo meta do projeto ou seja a
tendência é que isso seja democratizado
de fato a todos os cidadãos
muitas vezes o problema é o tempo né e
quando a gente fala principalmente de
mobilidade urbana as grandes metrópoles
nas grandes capitais elas acabam sendo
reféns de alguns poucos meios de
transporte
então uma das soluções que nós estamos
falando de acessibilidade de transporte
público é vai impactar diretamente a
dilma que tem 46 anos e mora em do
bairro qualquer a nova ordem a nova
ordem o transporte elétrico e também o
transporte aéreo via drones para pessoas
ou grupos pequenos né então existem já
empresas trabalhando para resolver esse
problema como por exemplo a vu do copar
da alemanhã e em também da china
não sei se vocês já viram eu vou voltar
mais lá e aqui não sei se vocês já viram
esse modelo mas ele já está em piloto lá
nos emirados árabes
dando seqüência o problema às vezes é o
conforto tempo não justifica
existem agora várias empresas
aproximadamente 10 mas eu vou destacar
três que irão impactar diretamente o
mike de 63 anos que é um executivo que
precisa fazer a conexão entre nova
iorque londres por exemplo com muita
velocidade trazendo dinâmica para que
ele fique mais tempo com sua família
então um mike ele vai usar os jatos
supersônicos que irão fazer viagens de
longas distâncias num período curto de
tempo
quem já está trabalhando nisso a nasa a
bom e ambas voltando com jatos
supersônicos ao ponto que você consiga
fazer uma viagem por exemplo de londres
para nova york em uma hora ou então não
você compra um produto na china em
receber no mesmo dia porque não né
além disso o problema pode ser a
autoestima ea praticidade
isso vai impactar diretamente a maya de
29 anos que mora em luanda porque
estamos falando de uma nova geração que
ainda não chegou de roupas ou seja de
vestuário
no qual você tem roupas que mudam de cor
que ajudam no seu controle tem de
temperatura ou seja só temperatura
corporal e além disso controlam
dispositivos como por exemplo da sua
casa ou então do seu dia a dia nem
interagindo com seus réus seus festivais
como relógio é decerto algumas marcas
que já estão trabalhando nesse sentido a
leves a polo ralph lauren e avance a
polo ralph lauren na olimpíadas do rio
ela fez um dispositivo é uma roupa que
ela já estava a temperatura corporal dos
atletas das olimpíadas nos estados
unidos
às vezes o problema é ética e isso é
muito importante então em 2030 é muito
provável que todas as nossas decisões
como consumidores sejam alinhadas
diretamente a e ética ou seja o respeito
às pessoas de um modo geral eu tô
falando às vezes de uma empresa que
terceiriza ou quarteiriza seus processos
e acaba muitas vezes sem ver contratando
trabalho escravo ou seja esse tipo de
informação ele será útil para a tomada
de decisão dos consumidores
então propósitos positivos empresas que
não são corruptas sem trabalho escravo
que pensam é no bem estar das pessoas
então por exemplo você vê um movimento
das grandes fabricantes de refrigerante
é claro comprando água empresas de água
empresas de chá empresas de suco
exatamente para tornar essa visão mais
saudável
algumas empresas já estão fazendo isso
como e levi ato de marketing e afluência
global que já possui no seu core
business no seu na sua coluna vertebral
a ética dentro dos seus processos muitas
vezes o problema e comunicação né
falando de comunicação isso vai impactar
diretamente o i am que tem 17 anos e ele
lá de gansu na china
eu estou falando que o idioma deixará de
ser uma barreira isso gerar um grande
gerará um grande impacto nas escolas de
idioma
recentemente eu conversei com os dos
proprietários de uma das maiores
escolas de idioma do brasil e tinha
acabado de voltar da china ele falou
assim eu vou ter que repensar o meu
negócio porque ele foi para a china
usando um dispositivo no qual ele ouve
chinês é a pessoa falar pra encher esse
eu vim português ele respondia a pessoa
também tinha um dispositivo ele responde
em português a pessoa ouve chinês ou
seja quando a gente fala de uma
videoconferência como no facebook contra
uma transmissão ao vivo então o a
microsoft através da sky do skype
você faz uma videoconferência falando em
português ea pessoa pode ouvir em
qualquer idioma ou seja o idioma não
será mais uma barreira às vezes o
problema em realizar um sonho né então
você quer realizar um sonho como por
exemplo torrents ocorrentes o ator 61
anos mora em concord nos estados unidos
ele tinha um sonho fazer uma viagem ao
espaço
então o turismo espacial é uma uma
referência pra eu seja em 2030 muito
provável que todos nós teremos a chance
de alguma maneira ou então pelo menos
evidências dessas chances de fazer um
turismo espacial é claro ver a pedra
espaço deve ser algo indescritível
então quem já está fazendo isso a spacex
além de só verde galactic do rio já
pensa que você tem mais cedo ea space
adventures entre outras empresas
tá às vezes o problema é posse e muitos
de vocês certamente hoje já não pensam
mais em adquirir um carro ou adquirir um
imóvel
eu estou falando que todos os produtos e
serviços deixaram de ser de propriedade
mas se tornaram um modo de assinatura ou
seja tudo como um serviço né
eu estou falando por exemplo do i live
que é do iwork a galera do utah e we
live no qual você paga uma assinatura
para ter uma moradia com um conjunto de
serviços igual você já paga hoje pra ter
um coaching você tem um colégio em mim
né
e não é alugar ou seja é um procon junto
de serviços então é a 1 lá essas service
a vida como serviço todos
a geladeira o carro à sua casa a
tendência é que todos os seja se tornem
serviços né
isso vai impactar diretamente o instinto
de 26 anos que mora em são petersburgo
na rússia
além disso quando a gente fala de
transporte é um carro nem acaba gerando
muito custo e centro
então a gente tem empresas como a
própria green que vocês já conhecem a
yellow de patinetes a zipcar de car
sharing e também acate o gol também nos
estados unidos que também têm carros
compartilhados
recentemente eu pude lá na europa
utilizar as motos da cimt escute e de
fato é muito prático você não precisa de
adquirir uma moto em uma moto disponível
sempre a hora que você quiser para levar
você do ponto a ao b sem qualquer
preocupação em pagar o ipva em colocar o
óleo e por aí vai
às vezes o problema de saúde isso vai
impactar diretamente o caso de 22 anos
de guadalajara no méxico porque haverá
uma nova reprogramação biológica
nanotecnologia para o sistema
imunológico e também para combater a
vícios
então você terá microrrobôs ou então
dispositivos químicos interagindo com o
seu corpo humano para combater doenças
reforçando o seu sistema imunológico
além disso combatendo vícios ou seja
você terá uma reprogramação biológica
dizendo olha aquela pessoa que tem uma
dependência química por exemplo poderá
ser reprogramada para que ela não tenha
mais isso
falando em nanotecnologia quem está na
frente disso sabe ouvir
já face é essa esse trabalho na
tecnologia iniciando algumas
programações para quem fazer hemodiálise
e também a selling que é uma empresa da
suécia ela está imprimindo órgãos
humanos de uma forma de é compensar o
enfim ajudar no processo de saúde
às vezes o problema é dinheiro né ou
então um registro de informações
então isso vai impactar a quem pode
impactar tomás 31 anos de belo horizonte
porque existe uma nova lógica existe um
o patamar é falando de registro de
informações que é o blog shopping que
pela primeira vez você tem a
possibilidade na internet de transferir
um arquivo ou então uma informação para
uma pessoa e que essa informação não
seja duplicada ou seja que ela passe de
fato para outra pessoa não é igual a um
anexo que você vai encaminhando via
email ou seja essa informação de fato
ela vai para outra pessoa
então isso abre um precedente para as
comunicar a parte financeira ou seja pra
revolução toda financeira em termos de
transferência de moeda facilidade de uso
é eu seja em qualquer segundo você
consegue transferir com segurança
dinheiro para outras pessoas em qualquer
lugar do mundo e o fim dos cartórios né
porque o bloco tinha ele permite uma vez
que você tenha propriedade por exemplo
de um imóvel
você consegue transferir essa
propriedade e registrar isso homologado
é de uma forma homologado por várias
outras pessoas
algumas empresas que estão na frente a
bitkom entrei com inglês e 7 ou falando
de krypton moedas mas tudo o que eu
disse agora pra vocês já é passado
ou seja tudo que eu disse agora é alguém
já pensou alguém já está fazendo
amanhã ou até mesmo hoje alguém já está
pensando além do que a gente está a
pensar né então futurismo também é você
constrói que você consolida os dados as
informações
isso se torna passado então certamente
em 2030 haverá coisas muito superiores a
essa até porque o crescimento é
exponencial
mostrei lá no início esse é um dos
maiores futebolistas do mundo que é o
rei cantou do google né
e fala até 2029 os computadores terão
inteligência emocional e serão um
vincent como pessoas
esse cara já prevê uma série de coisas
super legais depois vocês quiserem dar
uma olhada mas ou seja hoje ainda os
computadores não são uns convincentes
como pessoas
se você entrar num bote por exemplo
conversar com um robô
você vai rir porque não tem como a gente
tem que conversar língua dele não a sua
então na hora que a gente tiver um
computador convincente como pessoa é de
fato
a inteligência artificial irá gerar uma
grande revolução prática
e pra finalizar dong-won né
é a equipe do google ela tem esse lema
não tão vivo não seja mal né porque é
claro que tudo falando na nossa vida
como um todo inclusive na tecnologia a
gente pode fazer as coisas para o bem ou
para o mal
então o recado é tudo que a gente foi
construir força para o bem né
ou seja pensando na positividade do bem
estar das pessoas e uns maiores projetos
do google o google bem e ele fala nossa
missão com a equipe do google em é
tornar as máquinas inteligentes e
melhorar a vida das pessoas
pessoal muito obrigado espero que tenham
gostado
[Aplausos]